everyone to uh the Thursday the mice
research conference which we've been
trying to have back in um person and
we're working toward that um and next I
could tell you Lynn that um the Ed Tom
person uh just there's some decent
equipment in here so hopefully this
should go well and
um those who are online can interact
with
um uh those of us who here who are here
so it it gives me a great pleasure to
welcome my colleague
um Dr Tanashi matswangwa who is from the
University of Cape Town and so you might
wonder how
um I know Tanashi and he and I are
co-pies on a grant some of you know this
um the NIH has a initiative called the
data science Initiative for Africa that
is aiming to
build data science capacity in Africa
and not only
people capacity but also data capacity
so actually prior to that
prior to this project I actually had a
connection to the University of Cape
Town in that I served on the scientific
Advisory board for another project
called h3a bionet another NIH project
um and h3a stands for Health and Human
heredity for Africa
um and that project aims to build
capacity mostly around
um genomics and other omics
um so anyways um when this new
initiative came along
um we did what we all do we wrote a
proposal it got a good score and we got
funded and so now we have this
collaboration that is aiming to develop
a new graduate program in computational
omics and biomedical informatics at the
University of Cape Town
um and what we contribute to the project
because our health and clinical
informatics courses are online
we are contributing courses that
students in this program will be able to
take and then also
um because of my experience in
developing educational programs and um
so last quarter in the biomedical
informatics 510 course that I teach
there were actually seven students
enrolled from the University of Cape
Town
um in the course because it's an online
course and in fact I happen to be in
Cape Town in February and actually got
to meet those seven students in person
which was fun okay so then let's um move
on to our um topic today so um Dr
matvangua is an associate professor at
the University of Cape Town
in
um in the department of biomedical
engineering and
um that is his
formal training he's actually originally
from Zimbabwe but did all of his
education at the University of Cape Town
a bachelor's degree in electrical
engineering master of science in
medicine and biomedical engineering and
a PhD in biomedical engineering his
research area is mostly around Imaging
which we'll hear about and it's great to
see not only the demise Imaging people
but other Imaging folks from around
campus so I will
um let him proceed
okay
okay uh thank you very much for the
platform that's a great pleasure and
thank you very much uh for first for the
invitation so
um I'll speak to you a little bit about
um Medical Imaging within the context
that I'm actually working in some
aspects may be a little bit different
because we have different constraints
um just based on
um
um just uh
yeah
um different resources that are
available to us but uh some things may
be familiar
um it's not too technical it is not as
technical as some of these things can be
but if it does get a little bit too much
please just let me stop and then ask me
some questions afterwards or during that
Focus also
okay so I have to do some promotion
because that's how we do when you visit
um the University of Cape Town let's
start off with where Zimbabwe is so
Zimbabwe is there in red now South
Africa is just below Zimbabwe at the
most bottom tip of Africa
Cape Town is at the corner of the most
uh bottomless country or in Africa and
that's where the University of Cape Town
is um this is our main campus and this
is what that's what it looks like with
um just on the side of a mountain
similar to which you you guys have
um and the market behind there is
basically Table Mountains if you've ever
heard of Cape Town that's the Table
Mountain this part is not so much of a
table it's the other side you know you
have to look at it from a different
direction to to see that that aspect
um but formerly the so in terms of
information about the University of Cape
Town responded in 1829 as a South
African College
it was established as a university in
1918 and in terms of enrollment for
students it's about 20 plus minus 27 000
students and 4 500 staff across six
faculties so we have Commerce
engineering and the built environment
Health Sciences faculty Humanities law
and and science faculties
so because I'm in the faculty of Health
Sciences I'll elaborate a little bit
more on that faculty um so that was
founded in 1912 we have about 500 and
something academic staff 11 academic
departments and about 4 000 students are
enrolled
um plus or minus four thousand and one
of our biggest uh claims to fame um I'll
talk about the Imaging one later
um is that uh we're we're situated next
to krutus gear Hospital which is where
the first heart transplant was actually
done in 1969 by Professor Christian
Barnett
in terms of my own background as Bill
said I'm an associate professor in
biomedical engineering but my focus is
in medical imaging
I'm also an Associated researcher at EMT
Atlantic in France and I'm the group
lead of the medical image based
inferencing and distributed diagnostic
research group our me2d2 for short
so the me too stands for medical image
based inferencing in our areas of
research our Imaging and image analysis
analysis solutions for computer-aid
diagnosis and resource limited settings
and we use methods from machine learning
deep learning Etc statistical shape
modeling for this aspect the D2 stands
for distributed Diagnostics in our area
of research here is in M health and
telemedicine and the Technologies we
employ at things like blockchain X Road
augmented reality I will not be speaking
about that aspect today I'll be focusing
mainly on the medical image based
inferencing
the group consists of one academic staff
member uh with that's myself one Junior
research fellow so there's no yes after
the fellows
um one plus two one postdoctoral fellow
uh seven PhD students and two Master's
students
and in terms of
um their clinical areas that are
operating and this is the disorders and
diseases we focus on tuberculosis fetal
alcohol syndrome cervical cancer
Hodgkin's lymphoma osteoporosis and a
variety of other musculoskeletal
disorders so my talk today will be
focused on more oriented on the
musculoskeletal disorders but I'll speak
a little bit about our work in Fast and
tuberculosis as well in terms of medical
imaging
a bit of a disclaimer so I'll be
speaking I'll talk about law resource
settings and I'm sort of conflating that
with the rest of Africa but I don't know
much about what's going on in the rest
of Africa to be honest I know things
that are happening in my corner of the
woods but I think a lot of things do
sort of um
the situations are more or less similar
for the most part
um but yeah just to say that it's that
the presentation is biased towards my
own context and I have no disclosures or
no Financial disclosures or conflicts of
interest with the material I'm
presenting today
so let's go to the Imaging what are the
main Imaging modalities well you have
x-ray
you have CT
yeah ultrasound
and MRI and we can broadly divide these
into two categories so 2D Imaging
primarily from X-ray and ultrasound and
3D imaging from MRI and
um
NCT
so that's just to set uh set a bit of a
of a framework for how I'm going to
outline the talk moving forward but
before I could go to the to those
aspects I just wanted to maybe highlight
some of the innovations that have come
out of Africa that people may not know
and some of the Innovation that's
actually going on uh today in terms of
the medical imaging space so
the CAT scan is actually co-conceived by
South African
um Allen Allen cormack you know together
with Godfrey Huntsville and they both
received the Noble Prize in physiology
1979.
um in South Africa we're also
responsible for the development of the
First full body X-Ray Scanner it's
called the low docs Lodo stat scan
featured in Gray's Anatomy at some point
in time
in 2007 the cape University University's
body Imaging Center was developed so
this was the first research only Imaging
Center I believe across the whole
continent
2014 the UCT spin-off by a company
called capre developed in the castle
system which incorporates fulfilled
mammography in automated best best
ultrasound
and
they're still conducting some tests
although I believe that they're being
bought out by an American company
and then in 2015 2017 cubic got their
first research only or research
dedicated MRI and PET CT scan
so I don't know if he had any
preconceived notions of what it might be
like in South Africa but it's this does
not paint a really bad picture right if
you just look at it at face value that
being said Cape Town South Africa is not
representative of the rest of South
Africa and it's definitely not
representative of Africa
so there are some challenges across the
continent
one of them is access to Advanced
Medical Imaging equipment
in a study in 2013 By malura at Al
um they reported that across the
continent at least in terms of CT
on app
oh did we get lost
looks like they got disconnected
that does
. so Lynn is Mitch Carter the one from
yeah itg that's running
uh yeah let me try to dial them back in
I don't know why they dropped thanks
Mitch okay thanks
it is disparity across different sectors
all right I think they had disconnected
and reconnected
but now the question is how we get your
slides back
um
um huh
oh well
all right Lynn are you guys there yeah
let's I'm trying to get the slides back
I can uh head back in there really quick
okay great thanks
you're back there for a second
thank you
yeah I thought that it said on the top
that the call had ended
there we go okay
so it's worth noting that the who
recommends that 90 of Imaging needs of a
country can be met by just a simple 2D
x-ray ultrasound machine per one million
people right but what we are trying to
do in my research group is now
reconsider what kind of information can
we get from an x-ray or from an
ultrasound so we can add some value
where it would not be available using
traditional 3D or Advanced scanners
I like this picture a lot so this is
um an artist I was a photographer his
name is Johnny Miller and he uses this
uh he uses drones to take images to show
sort of like the disparities in
different settings this is from a
neighborhood in Cape Town and what you
can see on the right side is a really
densely populated almost slum-like
um
neighborhood right next to a leafy kind
of sparsely populated
um
sort of a neighborhood and this is an
artifact of apartheid right so there was
a segregation or separation of groups
based on on racial grounds and that is
still largely uh present in a lot of
South African so there's this divide
here it's not really there but it's it's
kind of there right
and in Radiology we have a similar
divide we have you know areas
could be different countries it could be
even within a country different
um
sort of
neighborhoods or it could be different
uh social economic people from different
social economic statuses so they are
easy there's on one side easy access to
Advanced Equipment and the other side
you have no access to the most basic
Medical Imaging
so this has been termed uh the
radiological divide and it's it's been a
really motivating sort of
um
it's one of the things that has
motivated my research group and our
research thinking the most which is how
do we Bridge the radiological divide
using tools that are already available
in that space and sort of just adding
value
and one of the good ways of doing that
because we're living in the age that
we're living in is of course leveraging
machine learning and AI to do that
but in so doing one has to be quite
cognizant of like being too disruptive
um because you're not going to get a lot
of buy-in by the communities or the
clinical Personnel in the countries that
you're trying well there areas you're
trying to operate in so ethos of course
is to implement to focus on implementing
products into existing systems rather
than starting from scratch and replacing
existing systems right we're always
looking out for opportunities of what is
already there and they will try and make
that better than trying to start
something from from scratch
now the blueprint for our research group
is as follows
um
we are trying to leverage like I said
things that are already occurring
connect technologies that already are
available on the continent
there are a lot of Imaging devices which
are in relative abundance compared to
you know the more advanced notes
there's been a large penetration of
smartphones and telecoms
telecommunication Network
telecommunication so let's let's just
say advances in telecommunications in
Africa which has actually shocked a lot
of people
considering that we LeapFrog from you
know having a Dallin phone straight to
having a smartphone
um it's it's it's it's it's been quite
um a big jump and of course it's
advances in machine learning
so we uh
we Loosely use this blueprint but it's
basically trying to consider remote low
cost Imaging so if there's a piece of
equipment that's largely available in a
region we want to see if we can use the
fact that we can transmit data quite
easily uh to uh maybe a remote so to a
central server and do some processing
and then send back only what is required
back to the clinician
and so please take note of this
framework because I'm going to sort of
superimpose all the research that we're
doing on on this framework
so let's start with our Flagship project
which is 3D from 2D reconstruction of
x-ray
the motivation is that at least for the
PDX 3D patient specific anatomic
structures Aid visualization and
interaction with volumetric data set mix
planning
intervention planning a little bit
easier at mixed diagnosis easier if you
have a 3D if you have 3D data rather
than 3D data
and typically you'll get our 3D data
from CT and Mr but these are too
expensive for us to acquire maintain and
to train Personnel to actually use them
on the other side on the other side we
have in relatively in higher relative
abundance uh digital X-ray and
ultrasound but they lack the detail that
you would get from CT and Mr
so the idea is can we get a 3D like
structure from a 2D image in a way that
it can be either diagnostically useful
or it can be useful for surgical
planning or prosthesis design
and we're focusing on CT and x-ray
because there's a lot of trauma-related
injuries and so there's a lot of trauma
in there um in in South Africa and as
well as you know diseases of the Aging
as our population is also starting to
age
um so why is CT better than x-ray you
know you get a more comprehensive View
and CET uh like I said Interventional
planning is easier with CT and you know
diagnosis can be easier than CT
so we follow uh one of many approaches
but it's um one approach that I think is
um is is showing to be quite um
promising
so if you're given a patience to the
X-ray right
you would want to figure out how can we
get the 3D reconstruction just based on
that it's very fast information and
x-ray is a projection image so really
getting through the information directly
from that is very difficult the way we
go about it is we actually have a 3D
prior or a template this 3D prior is
actually developed from uh
um statistics about the populations that
we are aiming to intervene for
so it's parameterized and basically what
we try to do is do an analysis by
synthesis approach so we're trying to
analyze it 2D image using a 3D model
but because we have a 3D model we need
somehow to get it into 2D space at least
the state of the model when we sample
from the model into 2D space
so we somehow have to create a synthetic
x-ray of the current state so this one
is the morphable model it's moving right
now but the movement is basically
um just different states of this model
right so for each state what we want to
do is Project the current state into 2D
space
and we can use some metrics to compare
the synthetic X-ray and the real X-ray
and if they are
if they're similar then we can say
whatever state the model was in when it
generated that 2D synthetic x-ray is the
3D reconstruction
and they're not similar then we have to
go back into our model and then we have
to find another
um yeah another state right so then we
have an optimization Loop
if you want to read a lot a bit about
how we're doing this we have this paper
in the um electrical using biomedical
engineering by my PhD student uh
Cornelius
so what we have then is three modules
actually we have a module which does the
modeling then we have a module which
does the synthesis and then we have
another module which is doing the
optimization
if you look at the literature A lot of
people combine all of this into one
project so you might see one paper
trying to do this but we want to do it
in a way that it generalizes Beyond just
simple use cases so we split it into
three PhD projects
so let's look at the modeling part
the first part of the modeling module is
actually work that I did at EMT Atlantic
when I was a junior Chen in medical in
biomedical Imaging and to to get the
model what we do is we take patient data
CT segment that data here we're focusing
on the scapula
we do a rigid alignment of all our
training data into a non-rated
registration the non-rigid registration
houses to establish dense surface
correspondence
um between our training sets once we
have dense correspondence then we can do
statistics on each of the corresponding
points right
so
here I'm showing on the right hand side
it looks like just a normal 3D model but
of course the 3D model is made of many
many points right now each one of those
points is in correspondence across the
training data that's what I mean by
dense surface correspondence
then our training involves just some
sort of compression we talked we
typically use a probabilistic prince for
component analysis and from there we can
sample from our model and now we have a
model that's generative so it has
generating uh on the left you will see
the first principle component the
variation in the in the population
um for the first principal component in
the second principle component but on
the right we just randomizing the shape
parameters and creating basically
virtual sort of scapulators so this like
virtual patients right
and the idea is that somewhere in that
shape space in our statistical shape
space there could be a representation of
a page a real patient's shoulder
so if you want to read more about that
you can find an article
um it was a featured article in the
transactions of diametrical engineering
for my PhD student uh perform a PhD
student now John I wanted to do
something a little bit more General
the idea here is that okay we can do it
for shape but what if we want to
leverage the information the intensity
information in the image because that's
a good proxy for example for bone
density so for bone quality so we now
need to think of a way of combining the
statistics of shape variation with the
statistics of intensity variation but
what if we don't want to do it for just
one bone what if you want to do it for a
joint
so do we need to now incorporate pose
variation so that's a variation in pose
at at image acquisition time across our
trading population
so conceptually it's easy but in terms
of actually doing it it's not trivial
but we have we have a solution
so for more training example we can take
multiple features so the features that
we're looking at are shape intensity and
pose
so we have shared features intensity
features post features and we have to
put them in the same statistical space
for pose because pose is post variation
does not is non-linear you have to
um you have to do a little bit of
trickery so we have to project that into
a manifold but after doing that
bookkeeping you can combine
um all three
um features um the variability and all
features in the same statistical space
and we encode the very the variability
as deformation fields
they will use the gaussian process
um as our our compression uh so gaussian
process is just a multivariate
distribution of the functions where the
function here is the deformation fields
and that gives us then a generative
model where we can sample from that here
I'm just showing how you sample from
that you still have to do a bit of
bookkeeping to make sure that the pose
is extracted in a useful way but it
allows us then to be able to have new
joints new joints that are not in the
training set and that could be
representative of a patient
and so here's an animation
um this is from real data it's from I
think
40 page it's a model developed from
training data 40 patients off the
shoulder you can see that the joint we
can sample different orientations for
the numerous clavicle and the scapular
and the intensity here just to for it to
be easy to visualize is just red and
orange red and blue red is more dense
and blue is less dense right we're
sampling quite far from the mean
occasionally
um so it's a normal distribution or
models and normal distribution and when
it's far from the mean then the
intensity and the joint space Also
starts to look a little bit odd because
basically you are saying it's an
unlikely
scenario under the distribution that we
are looking at very close to the mean
like about the standard deviation or two
we can say largely this is kind of what
you'd expect to see in in in in in in
the population that you are trying to
model
40 patients is not a lot we obviously
would want to do that for a lot more if
you want to get more representative data
but here we're talking more about the
approach and in subsequent work
um you know we'll add in more data
if you want to read more about this is
and
um nikai paper and also more recently in
the journal medical image analysis
module 2 is an x-ray synthetic it's
x-ray synthesis so how do we get from
our 3D space to our 2D space before we
do the comparison of the patient's x-ray
and basically what we do is we use the
same technique that's used in video game
generation which is Ray costing right
not again
yeah I'm disconnected
it's connected to
okay sorry about that there's probably
some network error that keeps kicking it
off let me dial it back okay
thank you Mitch
then on that because we'll have to do
that
laughs
okay so now we have a 3D model we have a
way of also projecting our model and
this can this is done in real time so we
have our our
digitally reconstructed radiograph
rendering engine is GPU enabled
we can model different image and
geometries because we expect that we're
going to see different geometries when
we look at different machines you know
we've got family geometries you've got
um what is it just no more projection
Etc
and our renderer can also using second
order statistical methods we can decide
which areas we want to actually render
and that might be more useful for
example if you want to fit a bone in
pots like maybe the trabecular bone
first and then the court upon sorry the
cortical bone first and then the
particular bone which is you know kind
of if you like really why are you
modeling there because it's depending on
the image quality you're not seeing much
um but you can disc Cascade how you do
your fitting by fitting separately and
you get a more and more precise solution
for the optimization I have another PhD
student who has worked on this and the
idea what the one of the our primary
deciderator for our solution was to make
sure that we can model the uncertainty
in our reconstruction
um I don't know if there any clinicians
yet no period recognition but if you
tell people that you've done the
Reconstruction they probably want to
know what is the error that you they
connect what is uncertainty in their
reconstruction right given that this
problem is very imposed
so our approach is to use Monte Carlo
Markov chain and it's a sampling based
approach where the idea is to get a full
posterior distribution of our model
given the observed data and so that
posterior distribution is actually the
uncertainty that in our fitting
here I show it's going to be very
difficult to see there's a this is for
counterfeiting of one bone in 2D where
the model is black and then the target
is white and you can see that just using
the sampling based approach we can
actually get a good fitting
and just because we had the ground truth
here I can show you what it looks like
in 3D so that's actually the model in
Black being fitted onto
um
the target this would not be this is not
okay in real life you would not have the
um the ground truth of course if you
want to read more about that you can
find that in the shape me um workshop at
mikai 2020.
in terms of clinical applications
um I have the student who's working on
how can we use this for something
clinical
um a pilot study of sorts and the idea
is to be able to actually use this type
of approach uh for 3D bone density
estimation for osteopor for osteoporosis
screening
so osteoporosis uh basically
um
occurs when you start losing both bone
density and that can be for a variety of
reasons including Advanced age
disease medication in South Africa we
have a hard population who have a large
population that is living with HIV and
they have to take antiretrovirals and
anti-rate for virals make your bone
density decrease
and there's also breastfeeding so the
idea is to use this approach to fill
this onto 2D x-ray now there's some
detail that I'm missing here so for my
image our Imaging colleagues you might
be like oh how do you know what the
density information in the image
actually is
um because you know it's an x-ray you
need some sort of way of understanding
what the house will do the what
intensity means
um in terms of real density and so our
approach is to actually use uh Phantom
would be in in clinical in a clinical
when translate this clinically Phantom
an image and Phantom which gives us a
reading for what the intensity in the
actual x-ray is
um we've also tried to have faster
inference instead of the mcmc approach
which is really good it gives us a nice
answer a nice uncertainty estimation but
it is really slow because the sampling
based approach and so using an encoded
decoder Network we can actually do
faster inference and get our
reconstruction
and then in order to actually start
looking at soft tissue
um also being able to reconstruct some
soft tissue or trying to leverage
um differentiable rendering so it can
have an end to end a system for 3D from
2D reconstructions that's really
leveraging the power of of deep learning
um to do a little bit more than just
looking at both
so that's that studio construction from
2D x-ray now in terms of how it aligns
to our blueprint
we would imagine how you can imagine a
remote clinical site where they have a
digital X-ray and you would want to then
give them some information in 3D which
might be helpful for whatever reasons
that they might want because they would
securely
would have a provision for them to
securely transfer their patient for
Geographic image data we could do our
processing remotely and only send them
back maybe a diagnostic result a 3D
visualization for planning a fracture
type or whatever information that they
need so that's really Distributing the
Imaging
um and that's where the distributed
Diagnostics comes from
the benefits for a resource limited
settings cost effective it's accessible
um this approach and you know there'll
be also the idea that you use less
radiation
um for because using x-ray rather than
CT so for people who have compromised
immune systems this might be a useful
approach or for Pediatrics right
um and obviously a big benefit is the
time and cost uh efficiency so there's
uh this this approach would be faster
and less expensive than ctmri but this
would only work in a very narrow
scenario a situation so we're not saying
that this approach can and uh gets
remove the need to have those other
equipment we're just saying what in the
scenario where we can't get those what
can we do with what we do have so that's
really should be uh should be said
but let's look at looking at 3D from
reconstruction for 2D images which are
natural images
am I doing okay every time
um yeah it's 12 1208 okay
I'll go a bit faster so
here we're trying to look at fetal
alcohol syndrome diagnosis using images
uh fatal syndrome and basically occurs
um where it was due to prenatal alcohol
exposure it's a big problem in South
Africa and that's mainly because during
apartheid in the wine growing regions
Farm Workers used to not get paid in
cash all the time but sometimes in wine
and so there's a call there is a a
culture that's been sustained even after
apartheid ended of um of drinking
heavily particularly during weekends
so
um the the
thing about FAS is if it's diagnosed
early you can intervene early and
therefore the outcome is better
um but there are challenges in South
Africa we don't have many
dysmorphologists so it's very difficult
to do large-scale prevalence studies in
remote regions uh so they need maybe a
computer as a
computer-aid diagnostic agent to help
with their screening
um indirect anthropometry is quite
accurate so that's using digital images
uh um to take uh to to do the analysis
but because the areas uh or the
measurements that you really want to
take for using the face which is the
most distinguishing
or discriminating
um
set of features amongst you know the the
rest for future Augustine I mean they're
also neural cognitive
um node neural developmental issues and
growth retardation but the facial
features at least a constellation of
facial features is the most
discriminating so we focus on that for
the diagnosis but the the type of
measurements you want to take are you
know from a 3D person you're trying to
simulate what a dysmorphologist would do
in 3D and so doing that on a 2D image
even with a with a a scaling marker is
is still missing the mark but there's
also a missed opportunity to look at the
face as a whole instead of just focusing
on only on these areas that this
morphologists look at particularly when
you start thinking about
um
the fact that some of the the criteria
for the facial ship analysis has been
developed in the global North and we
don't know if it directly applies in the
global South right so we want to keep
our options open
so 3D imaging is the way to go but 3D
imaging is extremely costly because you
need a 3D scanner so here we're trying
to do uh 3D from 2D reconstruction and
see can we get really good geometries
just by analyzing a 3D image using our
3D from 2D approach
and this is working collaboration uh
with the University of Basel formerly
but also Now with uh Frederick Alexander
University
um in Ellington in Germany
and it's called an analysis by synthesis
Loop so it's very similar to what I said
for the X-ray but here we're doing it
for natural images and the idea is you
have a morphable model it's
parameterized that's what's on the right
one set of parameters is for shape the
other one is for texture which will be
capturing you know things like skin tone
Etc and so you're trying to find the
parameters that are descriptive of your
image
right so if you see on the left ear you
have your input image that's Tom Hanks
and
maybe I have to start it again just so
that it's easy
you have an image of Tom Hanks and you
put your model in in the um
an analysis and then you try and find
the right parameters for Tom Hanks and
at the end of it you have that
representation of him which is a 3D
model
they've used this primarily at
Ambassador they use this primarily for
perception understanding so it was not
focused on the geometry whereas if you
want to use it for future alcohol
syndrome you need to focus on the
geometry
so the work from my former Master
student of mine was to actually see can
we actually do this and see how accurate
the geometric um
the
geometric measure is uh geometric
accuracy and what we've found in our
um in our assessment is that no we can
actually get reasonably good geometries
from this approach but we can do even
better maybe by adding another
perspective so instead of asking in a
clinicians he is just one picture maybe
getting through a profile picture and uh
or two 45 degree pictures or a profile
picture in a frontal picture and that
definitely helps but this was just a
pilot study to see if the approach would
work and we're not using a population of
children with fetal alcohol syndrops the
next step is to actually go and collect
data and show that this can work to
capture both syndrome I'm gonna read
more about that paper you can find here
so does that align to our blueprint the
idea is if you have a smartphone you can
then use a healthcare worker and uh at
this public school in every in a rural
area can take a whole collection of
images and then we can in a similar way
as before uh transfer the the data do a
reconstruction and flag for
um for whether that subject of the
patient sorry needs to be
um to go for the full battery of tests
so it's not going to be a diagnostic
tool it's going to be a screening tool
um because we just don't have enough
resources for our dysmorphologists to to
go to all these schools
um and the benefits are largely seamless
I'm not going to go through them the
last thing I'm going to go through is
improving latent tuberculosis infection
screening
so TB is a respiratory disease caused by
myobacterium tuberculosis it's a leading
cause of death by a single infection
infectious agent and in South Africa and
Africa generally sub-Saharan Africa we
have a disproportionate um
well
TB is a big problem
um now most people were exposed to TB if
you're not immunocompromised you know
you may not you may not actually get
um an active TP you might just get
latent TB
um but given that we have uh populations
that uh you know people live with HIV
Etc whose immune systems are compromised
um that becomes a big problem so we have
a lot of people who have we have a lot
of um issues with LTD becoming active TD
particularly intense in in the slabs
let's let's say like that but intensely
populated regions
that being said
of course uh it's uh there's
preventative therapy for for MTB and you
can cure LTB and and prevent uh
progression to LTB but the idea here is
to try and do the diagnosis as early as
possible
and and so I'll go through the sort of
standard of care for some the standard
screening approach in South Africa which
is the Manchu tuberculine skin test
although we are more and more also
getting um egress
as part of the of the screening chain
but e-grides is a bit of a logistical
nightmare because then you have to take
all the samples back and all that stuff
so the the chase the Manchester is still
the predominant test and I don't think
it's going to change anytime soon in
fact I think they're even more skill
tests uh that are coming along but I'm
not in that field I'm in the middle
ground if you feel so don't quote me
so how does it work or you inject
bacolin and the patients in the subjects
forearm
and after 48 to 72 hours an injuration
develops and depending on the size of
that injuration which is measured rather
crudely by a pendant ruler method it's
been like that for years and years
um depending on that size you can decide
um and uh and a bit of the patient's
history you can see you can say
something about whether or not they have
ltp so if a patients living with HIV
they might have a different
classification in terms of the size of
the injuration that's required for a
positive
problem
one of the problem is that
um for the boundary of the integration
because some sometimes intuition is
really subtle so you have to palpate in
order to get the edges but the
boundaries are always really sound so
try to use an image based approach is
not helpful but even for clinicians who
are using a rule and Pen method in
Darker skin individuals we actually
observe a lot of intro Observer error
repeating that measurement is not you
know even with lots of training is you
don't always get good repeatability so
that's one problem the other problem of
course is the 48 to 72 hour period
between the
application and the reading so for a
variety of reasons uh patients may not
come back for that reading um because
either it's too far they don't have the
money they have conflicting priorities
like work etc
and
if you don't get that evaluation within
that window then that invalidates the
test results and that you know you miss
opportunity to like to give treatment
and and it impacts the screening and
stability so you don't really know where
where the the LTE
which which areas we should focus on
resources on basically
so we've come up with an approach uh I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
Battle Before I show you the latest
version of that approach but the first
approach we tried was 3D reconstruction
of the duration based on a smartphone
image we developed an application
um that would guide the user to be a
self-administered test so they would
just scan over their arm and then
introduce time of flight to do a 3D
reconstruction of the in duration and
then we could like compare with you know
the standard pin and ruler which is the
ground truth in this case but that was
proving very difficult because RGB
Imaging is not really good at capturing
the extent of the integration and it
becomes a more difficult for darker
toned individuals so we needed an
approach that would actually look
subdermally and see if we can actually
see that reaction is something that
has some features that are that are that
you can image using some imaging
technology and we went for hyperspectral
Imaging
now you might be saying uh if you're
going to use a hyperspect or camera we
have we have one that it's
extraordinarily expensive how does that
work in a resource low resist setting
it's kind of the hitting the purpose but
what we have rationalized is that we
actually want to use a hyperspectral
Imaging to develop a classification
framework
um and characterize in durations because
we can see a lot more with hyperspectral
imaging but concurrently
for every patient that we Imaging we are
also taking an image with a smartphone
in using the RHP and then the idea is
once we get a good classification or
characterization for another type of
spiritual Imaging we can use transfer
learning to transfer
um that classification framework for for
smartphone images and then we can then
in in terms of deployment just use only
the smartphone
our results are promising and my student
or PhD student has just submitted to me
okay
so in terms of the blueprint it kind of
is kind of similar to everything else
it's remote
uh it could be a self-administrative
test which would be ideal and that that
that removes this 42 48 to 72 hour issue
but it could also be applied by a
healthcare worker in a district where
you know you know that at least from the
perspective of getting a consistent
reading we have removed the bias in the
subjectivity from the pin and Rule
Limited
so yeah the benefits are largely the
same
um of course this uh this is a research
projects
um and so we have to think a little bit
about the past implementation there are
lots of things that we have to take care
of none of these projects is mature
enough that we're doing large-scale
clinical trials
um but some of them are some of the
projects are involving clinical patients
for example the TD project we're
actually uh piggybacking on another
study where they're applying um the TST
to a lot of people in a lot of
healthcare workers who are working in in
areas of high prevalence of TB and so
we're getting a lot of data from from
these and so far the results are looking
promising
the other ways of of Bridging the
radiological divide and some of them are
through capacity building and that's
kind of linked to what me and Bill are
working on
um so in terms of training and education
I'm involved in a lot of initiatives
across the continent
um in terms of teaching Ai and and and
and and and things of that nature to
um students across the continent
have a group has a
a growing list of collaborators we're in
discussions with um
the dodox um private limited were who
developed the first full body school
network to see if we can incorporate
some of our technology into their
devices
the work that I'm doing has been funded
in part by
um you know the National Institutes of
Health South African National Research
Foundation Swiss swissness National
Foundation the DFG in Germany and um our
French partners
and we also I also try to advocate in
you know sort of to lay people you know
by giving Ted Talks and talking about
how we can Bridge The Divide
girls may have already spoken about this
but we have a joint project
um sponsored oh funded by the National
Institute of Health as part of the data
science Africa initiative
we'll try to develop a two-year Masters
and four-year PhD and faculty training
program leveraging our respective
expertise
this is the team
um we have Bill
um then from Mulder and Dr mendu and
myself as part of the leadership those
are stated aims
thank you very much
okay so um we have some time for
questions we have people here in the
room or we can't see the WebEx very well
so if there's like questions in the chat
someone's gonna either the person who
typed them is going to have to speak up
or someone's going to need to read them
but any questions
yeah
terrific
talk very interesting uh I guess this is
um I mean at the root of this one of the
problems seems to be
data acquisition how you get sort of the
ground truth in the places being you
know rural areas or places that are so
underserved I guess
um so
how do you
how do you think about sort of the
biases and the training data sets as you
go forward
um how do you how do you think about
capturing I guess a heterogeneous enough
uh population to serve as a training set
for this
so that's a very good question and I I
don't know if my answer is going to be
satisfactory at all
but one of the things at least because I
come from the world of working with
statistic or shape models and we've
always understood in that community that
getting a representative data set is an
issue so what we always try to do is
match our application to the demography
that we are actually working on
so applications are always very specific
and very targeted try to scale that up
to you know something like a system
where you're trying to get
representation across a whole region
list a whole you know Province or
something in South Africa is it's going
to be difficult and South Africa
it's a really really heterogeneous
population so
I think in my mind
and I don't mind to confess this I've
kind of pushed that problem a bit
further whilst I was we worked on the
tech we feel like that's something that
is a discussion you have when it comes
to implementation but the the the
technical things that you have to do in
the background and it's for the majority
you can do by abstracting away that
problem and then when it comes to okay
now we actually want a clinical solution
then you really have to think okay now I
need a representative model so that's
one way of doing it the other way that
we have been doing it is to maybe try
and have bias mitigation strategies that
are more technically grounded like
popular component analysis and stuff so
you know so factorize out the different
uh confounders based on any of um the
secondary information we are getting
from our patients so we can make our
models more agnostic
but I don't know how that scales so I
I'm sure that's not satisfactory but
yeah thank you for that that was really
uh wonderful talk so in terms of
resources
you know there have been some really
uh impressive Innovations Coming Out of
Africa and um limited resources often
challenges you to think about things
generally which I think is wonderful
um
so can you tell us a little bit about
the infrastructure for sharing images
and what the opportunities are for maybe
getting access to all images that have
been collected in what those barriers
might look like and yeah
so I can talk about data sharing
generally because I think it's
informative
um and Bill made became way in
um part of what we're doing as part of
this data science Africa initiative is
just opening up avenues for more data
sharing generally and I think that
there's a big drive for that
um I think there's maybe some hurdles
around you know sort of different
um what is it politics in different
countries and stuff but these are things
that can be overcome I believe the world
is there and so that that that's just
general information in terms of from our
particular work we are as open as as
possible but I don't think we have the
numbers that people might expect and
that is a bit of a problem
um recently we just um
um we spoke to the head of radiology
after many tries to try and open up the
pack system so we can actually really
start doing something a little bit more
you know
um
this is not really validate whether this
approach is actually work but in terms
of the data that we have enriched
ourselves and I I don't have any issues
you know with with an agreement in place
to share that kind of data in fact
that's what we want
um and I can tell you that myself and uh
collaborated at the University of Basel
we've actually started a platform an
online platform
um which is called the shape the world
it's a bit tongue-in-cheek because of
our shape modeling the idea is to put
um all these models on this platform
that are already developed and validated
so that other people would have to go
through the growth planes that we went
to and also to have a platform where
people can discuss methods for
um how to build applications on top of
these um these models so I'm as open as
in in terms of Open Source as as
possible yeah
and you know the the DSi Africa project
you know which is NIH funded is um you
know it's that there's all there's many
facets of capacity building you know
there's human capacity building there's
data capacity there's also
infrastructure so they're negotiating
agreements you know just like NIH you
know even here and you know yeah you
know it's a real barrier yeah yeah so
it's a lost opportunity right yes yeah
having access to data yeah so getting
some of the cloud providers to
um
you know provide space you know in their
Cloud for uh yeah I I think some of the
barriers that we've seen that are are
just is at the institutional level
s these cultures within the institution
when it comes to sharing yeah yeah
it takes a lot of effort but really
worthwhile when you've got innovative
models and and you'll drive yeah yeah
you know there's another NIH project I
was just in DC earlier this week called
bridge to Ai and
the at least for now the the big cloud
providers you know Microsoft and Google
are chomping at the bit you know they
want to you know I'm sure they kind of
see the long-range benefits to them
doing it and hopefully they'll they
won't you know at some point pull the
plug or whatever but um that they've
been very you know amenable to you know
providing
capacity
sounds good do we have any any questions
or comments from the WebEx
nothing in the chat
okay okay well it's actually just about
time so
um
um I want to thank um Tanashi for giving
this talk and and as one who's actually
not an Imaging person I I found it very
um understandable in terms of of what
you're doing and I can see a lot of the
clinical correlates so uh so that's
great and um
um you know and maybe going forward now
that we have this formal collaboration
with the University of Cape Town there
might be some opportunities to
collaborate in other ways besides our
initial educational one so thanks again
and um thank you all for coming
[Applause]
and then
um we'll
um pause for about 15 minutes and uh